Suiza seguirá siendo verde en 2050 desde
hoy también estará obligada a ser neutra
en emisiones de carbono para ese mismo
año los ciudadanos votaron en referendo
a favor de la denominada como ley del
clima importante Éxito para la
protección del clima y la seguridad de
suministro la población claramente dice
Sí a la ley de protección del clima la
campaña de noticias falsas del sbp no
funcionó el ultraderechista partido
popular suizo había iniciado una campaña
contra la ley que fue tomando fuerza
entre los ciudadanos aseguraban que se
prohibirán todos los combustibles
fósiles o que los paisajes alpinos se
verán cubiertos por placas solares para
algunos ciudadanos sin embargo la ley se
queda corta
[Música]
porque 2050 queda muy lejos deberíamos
haber votado no diré para el año que
viene no soy tan optimista pero digamos
que para 2030
la aprobación llega dos años después del
rechazo a otra ley por los nuevos
impuestos que implementaba esta nueva
propuesta es también un texto de
consenso llegó tras eliminar un segundo
proyecto popular denominado iniciativa
por los glaciares Este sí pretendía
prohibir todos los combustibles fósiles
para 2050 para este experto de
greenpeace la aprobación es un mensaje
para el mundo
creo que esta ley es muy importante para
enviar una señal que Suiza quiere actuar
para alcanzar el acuerdo de París creo
que esta ley aunque sea insuficiente
puede tener un gran impacto mundial
[Música]
según el texto todas las entidades
estatales deberán alcanzar la
neutralidad en 2040 habrá también 3.200
millones en ayudas para una renovación
tecnológica verde ahora el parlamento
deberá encontrar nuevas medidas para
alcanzar los objetivos